et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Marine tondeuillier bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous secrétaire
national d'Europe Écologie Les Verts on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Eric Richard
de la Nouvelle République bonjour Éric
bonjour Oriane bonjour marine Tondelier
bonjour
de retraite marine tondu les nouvelles
journées de manifestation et de grève
aujourd'hui qui s'annonce mon suivi que
les précédentes que les mobilisation est
en train de s'essouffler c'est les
vacances scolaires on savait depuis
longtemps que ce serait un moment plus
compliqué dans la rue mais vous savez je
note que même quand on parle de
démobilisation c'est quand même des
chiffres records par rapport aux
manifestations des dix dernières années
donc c'est une mobilisation qui a
historique sur un sujet qui est
historique mais en réalité en plus les
gens manifestent bien plus que contre
les retraites c'est après des mois des
années d'humiliation un pays qui relève
la tête qui manifeste pour cette dignité
c'est un très beau sujet la dignité et
je pense que ce qui est en train de se
passer dans la rue ne s'arrêtera pas en
fait à la réforme des retraites que
c'est quelque part un nouveau départ
pour ce pays aussi
cette réforme est adoptée vous pensez
que les mobilisations vont continuer
vous vous souhaitez qu'elle continue
même les humiliations qui ont été
accumulées vont pas disparaître parce
que trois députés de plus votre un
article ou un texte que que celles et
ceux qui votent contre ou parce que le
gouvernement accélère le débat ou parce
que on décide que les débats est terminé
qu'on passe pas ordonnance ça c'est
clair et c'est pas de mon fait hein les
syndicats qui souhaitent mettre la
France à l'arrêt le 7 mars vous
souhaitez aller jusque là vous mais
évidemment évidemment que c'est
nécessaire et que à la rentrée scolaire
on nous a dit les vacances faut pas
toucher c'est important pour les
Français nous sommes aussi français des
Français nous aspirons je pense qu'il y
a très peu de français des Français qui
partent en vacances en réalité aux
vacances de février mais bon c'est aussi
un moment de pause on profite des
enfants ok mais à la rentrée et je pense
que c'est un souhait très général de la
population française les mobilisations
vont repartir de plus belle avec la date
du 7 vous en parlez mais je voulais
aussi insister sur le lendemain le 8
mars qui la journée internationale des
droits des femmes et je pense nous
étions hier en meeting avec Politis avec
des femmes syndicalistes artistes
intellectuels politiques je pense que ce
qui va se passer le 8 mars va être un
très grand avons aussi de ces
mobilisations retraite parce que les
femmes vont rentrer en action on voit
que il y a très très peu d'avantages à
être une femme dans le monde et dans la
société française il y en avait un tout
petit c'est que les trimestres de
grossesse étaient pris en compte dans
lequel qui de retraite et même ça même
ça ils veulent nous le prendre on voit
que les économies qui sont cherchés sur
la réforme de retraite vont être prises
en particulier sur les femmes et les
femmes n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot le
8 mars elle rentre en action qu'est-ce
qui va se passer concrètement elle
rentre en action ça veut dire quoi ben
je pense que les femmes vont massivement
prendre leur part ce jour-là elles sont
déjà elles sont déjà en émission que
vous organisez quelque chose si vous en
parler de quelle manière une grève des
femmes qui est peut-être moins suivie
les autres années mais je pense que
cette année elle prendra
particulièrement son sens pour beaucoup
de femmes qui suivent ça de loin qui ont
pas le temps qui ont passé en tête là je
pense que chaque femme active
une grève des femmes le 8 mars et vous
allez organiser à moi je pense que c'est
vous allez organiser des mobilisations
spéciales vous ah bah le 8 mars toute
façon il y a toujours eu des
mobilisations sociales et les
écologistes sont toujours été totalement
intégrés à cela je pense que cette année
ça prendra des retraites et mobilisation
évidemment et puis soutient aux femmes
qui se battent de manière très
courageuse dans le monde en Afghanistan
en Iran nous serons aussi en pensés avec
elle évidemment ce jour-là ce débat sur
la réforme des retraites vous le suivez
de très près j'imagine le débat
parlementaire comment est-ce qu'il
évolue à vos yeux est-ce qu'on n'est pas
un peu dans une impasse il est clair
depuis le début que c'était pas parti
pour bien se passer on a un gouvernement
qui a choisi tous les modes opératoires
pour que le débat soit le moins le moins
intéressant possible donc là je note
qu'il y a une volonté et je m'en
félicite des groupes de la nupesse
d'accélérer de retirer des amendements
pour qu'on discute en fin de cette qui
est quand même le cœur du débat et je
pense que les Françaises et les Français
ont envie d'entendre leur parlementaire
officiellement s'exprimer officiellement
voter voir ce que à la fin il fait
pouvoir l'interpeller pouvoir voir ce
que parce que les gens qu'on a élu 10 et
uniquement la faute du gouvernement
c'est pas aussi la photo millier
d'amendement déposé par la nuque pour
vous voyez il y a aussi le fait on a
débattu de cette index senior dans tout
le monde s'accordait à dire d'ailleurs
que il était pas efficace et c'était pas
utile on en a quand même débattu un
certain nombre d'heures d'amendements
alors sur
suscite des débats parce que c'est on
trouve que c'est pas utile mais donc si
le gouvernement contraint extrêmement
nombre de jours se débat bah si il reste
peu de temps alors allons à l'essentiel
à cet article 7 et vous savez je pense
que celles et ceux qui nous aident pas
débattre de l'article sec c'est sûrement
pas les parlementaires de la gauche et
des écologistes à mon avis c'est plutôt
le gouvernement qui a pas intérêt et on
verra si ce débat se tient sereinement
ou pas il y a eu des retraites
d'amendement hier de centaines
d'amendements combien les écologistes en
ont retirées je pense qu'ils en ont
gardé une quinzaine qui leur paraissait
vraiment essentielle une quinzaine avant
l'article 7 ouais et donc ils ont gardé
évidemment ceux de l'article 7 et après
il y a encore beaucoup d'amendements de
la France insoumise est-ce que vous
demandez à la France insoumise de
retirer plus d'amendements j'ai vu hier
ils savent ce qu'ils font moi je suis
pas là pour donner des consignes au
parlementaires ils sont grands les
groupes parlementaires ont leur vie
débattre prennent les décisions
sur les régimes spéciaux il y a plein
d'amendements c'est normal c'est ce qui
a attendu de parlementaire d'ailleurs
donc voilà on fait le travail du mieux
qu'on peut vous pensez pouvoir remporter
le vote sur l'article 7 moi je suis pas
astrologue ce que je sais c'est que ça
va pas être aussi simple que le
gouvernement de penser on voit que même
chez eux ça dépasse c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a même les macronistes doutes de de la
réforme macroniste que chez les
républicains c'est aussi compliqué que
ça négocie d'ailleurs il y a
exclusivement en débat entre la bigar
mars et les républicains parce qu'ils
font ensemble mais ils ont l'air de
passer beaucoup de temps ensemble en
tout cas c'est c'est leur réforme c'est
c'est une aventure conjointe apparemment
et qui ont voté contre l'article 2 avec
vous bah oui parce que je pense que
c'est un texte qui est très compliqué
depuis le début ils le savent et c'est
pour ça que par l'acheter un petit peu
ils font tout pour que le débat soit
escamoter finalement vous le disiez vous
vouliez vous avez dit vouloir
transformer l'Assemblée en ZAD en zone à
défendre est-ce que vos vœux ont été
exaucés au-delà de ce que vous espériez
moi quand je parlais de zone à défendre
c'était défendre les droits que comme
nous avons défendu et sauvé le bocage de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes qui est encore là
il y a pas d'aéroport à notre améland
l'agriculteurs peuvent continuer à
cultiver la terre sur laquelle ils sont
nés et bien je souhaitais que nos droits
sociaux soit une zone éléphant mais ce
qui est en train de se passer ce que
vous voulez me faire dire c'est que ça
justifie toutes les outrances la réponse
est non je pense qu'on a énormément de
choses à dire sur le fond cette réforme
et non énormément de débats à voir sur
les valeurs qui sous-tendent des
positions des uns et des autres c'est
hyper intéressant et c'est très
éloquence pour vous notamment de la part
de la France ils sont allés parce qu'en
fait quand il y a des dérapages qui
d'ailleurs sont absolument pas
représentatifs de ce qu'est de ce que
sont les parlementaires écologistes
nupais etc mais à la fin c'est un cadeau
fait au gouvernement parce qu'ils sont
tellement mal à l'aise sur le fond de ce
dossier que toute mini perche tendue qui
leur permet de de passer quelques heures
à parler de la forme de la prise de
parole de tel ou tel plutôt que du fond
du dossier ça les serre ils sont
tellement fébrile que tout occasion est
bonne pour eux de sortir du débat de
fond je pense que nous on doit se
concentrer là-dessus les valeurs le font
et pas leur faire ce cadeau de pouvoir à
chaque fois dériver autre chose Emmanuel
Macron adressé un message aux
oppositions hier en conseil des
ministres il a dit les oppositions ont
plus de boussole et sont totalement
perdus qu'est-ce que vous répondez
franchement alors lui je sais pas où il
est depuis quelques jours il est pas là
c'est un moment qui est crucial pour la
vie politique française il y a des
manifestations record comme jamais il y
en a eu depuis 10 ans et lui il était
pas là il essaie en première ligne c'est
ministre sa première ministre je me
disais mais qu'est-ce où est-il et là on
conseille des munistes il fait des c'est
des fanfaronnades finalement ce qu'il
fait il est voilà au chaud dans ce que
c'est des ministres alors que c'est ces
ministres sont en première ligne sur le
banc des ministres et lui il dit vous
lui demandez de s'exprimer sur cette
réforme bah oui qui prennent ces
responsabilités qui laissent passer
ministre seul c'est un peu lâche sinon
sur le rassemblement national qui a
déposé une notion de censurer oui donc
par rapport à cette motion je dirais
qu'elle va être votre votre position le
rassemblement national rappelle que
c'est la l'occasion de repousser en
quelque sorte cette réforme
quelle est finalement votre regard votre
votre stratégie
parce que fait Marine Le Pen là c'est un
coup politique le rassemblement national
dans le mouvement social dans la rue on
ne les voit pas je sais pas où ils sont
ils sont pas là ils servent à rien dans
ce mouvement social
bah oui mais ils sont pas là ils
pourraient faire autre chose il y a
plein de manières de manifester et le 19
le 31 le 6 la rentrée le 7 ils ne sont
pas là je sais pas où ils sont mais ils
sont pas là ensuite à l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai pas l'impression que il
brille par leur prise de position par
leur argumentation ils sont pas vraiment
là non plus c'est pas eux qu'on entend
et donc là ils sortent de leurs besace
cette motion de censure mais émotion de
censure pour faire quoi Marine Le Pen
elle a une majorité alternative à
proposer non Marine Le Pen a dit c'est
un référendum parlementaire on veut
savoir qui est vraiment pour cette
réforme qui est vraiment compte cette
réforme et ceux qui ne veulent pas la
notion de censure ce sont les alliés du
gouvernement oui bah ouais c'est petite
pantalonade
est-ce que c'est un coup politique
réussie est-ce que ça met la nuque dans
l'embarras absolument pas parce que je
vais vous dire ne pas voter des textes
du rassemblement national ça ne m'est
personne d'en embarras c'est même plutôt
un avec ce sang démocratique et
républicain mais vous savez ce que va
dire Marine Le Pen elle va dire que du
coup vous êtes alliés du gouvernement
parce que vous ne vous opposez pas
clairement cette majorité alternative on
sera ravie de d'avoir ces détails parce
que je ne comprends pas si sa motion de
censure est adoptée ce qu'elle fait
est-ce que vous vous en déposerez une
est-ce que les écologistes la nuque
déposeront des champs et je suis très
respectueuse de partir très très
respectueuse de la Ligue des Champions
évidemment qu'on en discute mais c'est à
eux de prendre ce genre de décision ils
sont toute la journée et c'est sûrement
pas moi depuis mon bureau de secrétaire
national qui va leur expliquer ce qu'ils
ont à faire c'est c'est leur mandat
c'est leur travail ils ont toute ma
confiance pour prendre les bonnes
décisions c'est eux qui ont la décision
vous avez voulu poser il y a peu le
débat sur le partage des richesses et
sur les inégalités c'est vrai que c'est
une question centrale mais vous l'avez
abordé il reste sous l'angle seul de la
fortune des milliardaires on a eu
l'impression que vous étiez pas très
bien comprises sur la forme
si vous y revenez vous je dirais est-ce
que vous y prendrez autrement pour
expliquer tout simplement moi je pense
que tous ceux qui comprendre ont compris
que ce qui n'avait pas envie de
comprendre n'ont pas compris Bruno Le
Maire notamment a dit elle veut une
France 100 milliardaire c'est une
coupeuse de tête mais moi je je m'en
prends au milliard pas ceux qui les ont
comme quand Stanislas Guerini dit qu'il
veut supprimer les fonctionnaires
personne n'interprète le fait qu'ils
veulent embaucher des des tueurs à gages
pour les attendre dans la sortie de
l'administration bah là c'est pareil par
contre Saül mérite de poser un débat sur
le partager richesse moi je refuse qu'on
ne joue qu'en défense sur nos droits
sociaux comme si on était la ligne
Maginot ou la la forteresse à siéger et
en réalité oui il y a un vrai problème
de partager ça chez je suis fier que ce
débat du coup se pose et se mêle à celui
de retraite parce qu'il est juste et
qu'en réalité
le gouvernement quand il a annoncé cette
réforme de retraite Elisabeth band son
élément de langage c'était c'est une
réforme de justice et puis quand c'était
une fake news évidemment que qu'on a
déminé et puis ils ont commencé à dire
ah ben non mais en fait c'est une
réforme d'effort c'est déjà pas la même
chose surtout quand on voit ce sur qui
pèse les efforts à la fin de cette
réforme et donc oui il y avait un vrai
sujet de partage des richesses au moins
il est posé
parler de votre partie
là qui vient de lancer les états
généraux de l'écologie alors vous vous
êtes fixé un certain nombre de casés
notamment 150 jours dites-vous pour
réussir la transformation du parti
avec quelle méthode et ça veut dire quoi
précisément ça veut dire que en 2023 les
personnes quoi qu'elles pensent dans la
vie et quoi qu'elles aient envie de
faire ne vont pas forcément vers des
partis politiques c'est vrai pour le
nôtre le parti écologiste mais c'est
vrai en réalité pour les parties de
manière générale et donc en 2023 nous
devons réinventer des manières de
s'engager et nous avons décidé parce que
nous sommes écologistes parce que nous
croyons à la construction la démocratie
ouverte d'associer toutes celles et ceux
qui le souhaiteraient parce qu'en
réalité c'est Bruno Latour qui nous a
quitté il y a quelques mois un
philosophe de l'environnement qui disait
majoritairement les écologistes
potentiellement les écologistes sont
majoritaires dans ce pays mais c'est une
classe écologique qui n'a pas conscience
d'elle-même qui n'est pas fière
d'elle-même qui n'est pas structurée
organisée en tout cas en face de nous
ils le sont et donc le travail que nous
avons à faire c'est de structurer cette
classe écologique que les personnes
soient mues par des intérêts
internationaux des risques mondiaux ou
par un projet local parfois par tous
cela en même temps qu'il soit électeur
d'un jour de toujours ou qu'il ne vote
plus qu'il soit inquiet pour leur petit
enfant ou pour leur quotidien leur santé
environnementale par exemple il y a
plein de manières d'être écologistes
nous devons offrir un endroit un espace
où celles et ceux qui se reconnaissent
là-dedans puis se lever la main dire moi
j'en suis comment j'aide et puis leur
proposer différentes méthodes
d'engagement certains veulent participer
aux élections faire des campagnes
électorales nous le faisons déjà mais
d'autres veulent plutôt être mis en
contact avec des personnes qui sont
confrontées aux mêmes sujets que leur au
même lutte au même projet qui veulent
porter nous devons organiser tout ça et
si on le faisait à notre image à nous
nous qui sommes déjà là bah alors ça
servir à rien puisqu'on est déjà là et
donc on veut on veut construire le parti
dans lequel ces personnes et envie
d'aller c'est pour ça qu'on va le
construire avec eux mais alors
précisément pour pour parvenir et c'est
une autre de vos c'est un autre de vos
objectifs pour pas venir un million de
sympathisants d'ici à 2027
est-ce que ça signifie pas qu'il
faudrait peut-être regarder l'échiquier
politique peut-être un petit peu plus
largement que vous ne le faites jusqu'à
lors pour fédérer un si grand nombre
faites comme si on était dans une partie
d'échecs et qu'on bougeait des pions en
disant on va les chercher cela
non en fait nous on va créer un grand
mouvement de l'écologie politique
le débat que je pose là n'a rien à voir
avec le débat de quel alliance pourquoi
faire c'est autre chose et on va pas non
plus refaire notre projet écologiste qui
existe les gens savent bien ça veut dire
quoi être écolos par contre ce qu'on
veut c'est créer l'espace d'engagement
qui soit inclusif où les gens se sentent
bien qu'on puisse renouer par exemple
les personnes qui habitent à la montagne
à 20 % de France à des Français qui
habitent à la montagne il y a des
problématiques environnementales autour
de la neige des retenues colinaires de
de tourisme et de cette industrie qui
doit forcément bouger qu'on soit
écologiste ou pas nous adressons ces
sujets depuis des années il y a de plus
en plus de gens qui dans les zones de
montagne disent bah oui nous on veut
travailler là-dessus c'est pareil pour
les ruralités c'est pareil pour le
littoral c'est pareil pour la France
périphérique c'est aussi pareil pour les
centres villes urbains nous ont à les
porter l'écologie sur ces territoires
avec les personnes et donc on va
organiser dans toute la France des
ateliers en plus de la grande enquête
populaire en ligne qui a commencé on va
aller voilà partout leur proposer ça et
puis on créerait un mouvement qui permet
de faire ça d'inclure les classes
populaires d'inclure les jeunes
d'inclure vraiment les préoccupations de
chacune et de chacun mais ça veut dire
que Écologie Les Verts a vécu qu'il faut
passer à autre chose bah oui c'est c'est
un mouvement je vous le disais en 2023
on peut plus aborder les parties comme
on le faisait y a 20 ans on ne sait on
est lucide la bâtir nous venons nous
nous principes ça sera tout changé tout
changer dans 150 jours nous venons
le nouveau nom on avait voté nous au
Congrès ça pouvait être les écologistes
qui paraît un nom plutôt clair on voit
ce qu'il y a derrière si on trouve mieux
et ben on fera mieux si celui-là
convient on prendra celui-là on est très
ouvert surtout comme je vous l'ai dit
Julien Bayou a fait son retour sur la
scène médiatique hier et il a dans
l'hémicycle il est le Europe Écologie
Les Verts
mais bon là il a fait son retour
médiatique Europe Écologie Les Verts à
Claude dossier faute de témoin sur les
accusations de violences psychologiques
de la part de son ancienne compagne
est-ce que cet épisode est un fiasco
pour votre partie
si ce que vous voulez me faire dire
c'est que le l'issue de ce dossier n'est
satisfaisant pour personne ni pour
l'ex-compagne de Julien Bayou dont on
comprend en plus qu'en fait elle a fait
un mail suite à une tentative de suicide
depuis son lit d'hôpital qu'elle envoie
à plein de gens dont la cellule violence
sexuée sexuelle de LV et qui a prédit
apparemment la cellule c'est auto sosie
mais en fait la procédure pour saisir
cette cellule était de faire un mail à
cette adresse donc elle a eu la
sensation que la cellules s'auto
saisissée la cellule a eu la sensation
d'être saisie donc déjà il y a eu un
quiproquo dès le départ que
l'enquête n'est plus n'est pas pu avoir
lu que la parole de son ex-compagne
n'est pas pu être recueilli pour plein
de raisons dont j'ai eu l'occasion de
discuter avec elle enfin je veux dire
là-dessus il y a pas de piège de c'était
pas le lieu adapté pour elle c'est comme
ça c'est pas satisfaisant pour elle
c'est pas satisfaisant pour Julien Bayou
qui aurait sûrement préféré qui est une
enquête à la suite de laquelle il puisse
être discuter et c'est pas satisfaisant
pour le parti et donc moi j'en tire
toutes les conséquences on a un audit de
cette cellule qui commence en février
qui était prévu depuis longtemps parce
que cette cellule on est le premier
parti et l'avoir mis en place on le met
en place aussi parce que la police et la
justice n'accueille pas correctement la
parole des femmes que c'est des sujets
qui sont pas bien traités donc on se
retrouve comme des entreprises des
associations en première ligne sur le
sujet donc on fait du mieux qu'on peut
et comme on est les premiers on défriche
on expérimente on fait pas tout bien on
le sait on l'a donné mais au moins on
fait pas seulement qu'il y a pas de
problème vous allez revoir son
fonctionnement voir son existence son
existence aussi elle est changé tout il
y a un an quand on a mis en place un
certain nombre de réformes de cette
cellule on s'était dit dans un an parce
que ces membres sont renouvelés là en
février nous ferons un audit externe et
on se posera très concrètement toutes
les questions qu'il faut mais à la
lumière de l'expérience acquisée
évidemment que ce qui s'est passé dans
dans le cas de Julien Bayou va être pris
en compte qu'on se posera les questions
de la présomption d'innocence qu'on se
posera aussi les questions de comment on
accueille la Parole comment une femme se
sent sécuriser et trouve que à la fin
cette cellule est le bon cadre pour
parler même quand il s'agit d'un cadre
assez haut placé du parti il y a
beaucoup de questions qui se posent et
on va se les poser avec des expertes des
associations qui sont connues et
reconnues sur le sujet et avec lesquels
d'ailleurs on a mis notre procédure en
place dès le début qu'on continue à
faire évoluer mais vraiment ce cas cette
accusation quand Julien Bayou ont mis
notre procédure à rue des preuves
vraiment on était dans une impasse et on
n'a pas eu d'autre choix que de chlore
cette affaire et donc on va en tirer les
conséquences parce que si on a été dans
l'impasse là on peut l'être à nouveau et
on le souhaite pas ce sera pour quand
donc les travaux ont commencé le cahier
des charges si vous voulez tout savoir
en bureau exécutif mardi on l'a écrit
ensemble pour être sûr de nous oublier
aucune question et donc on va on va on
est en train de chercher qui va faire
cet audit et une fois qu'il sera démarré
il y aura un appel aussi très large aux
personnes qui ont quelque chose à dire
dans le cadre de cette audit soit des
qui ont fait des signalements qui n'ont
pas pu parler soit des femmes qui ont
qui n'ont jamais osé même signaler
quelque chose et qui veulent nous
expliquer pourquoi et dans quel cas
peut-être il pourrait mieux faire des
signalements et parler on va vraiment
sans œillères sans ornière sans sans
essayer de cacher des problèmes adresser
tous ces tous ces sujets
puisque c'est dans 6 mois oui donc par
rapport à ces sénatorial alors on sait
que il y aura un certain nombre je
dirais de de candidatures et de et de
vocation
qu'est-ce que vous pensez notamment de
celle de Yannick Jadot je pense le sujet
avec candidature de Yannick Jadot c'est
parce que j'en pense moi c'est ce qu'on
pense déjà les personnes qui en
Île-de-France prendront la décision et
notamment à Paris de si les candidats à
Paris ou pas et puis que ça soit lui les
candidats à la candidature il a dit
clairement pas comme ça il y a pas de
fait du roi ou de la secrétaire
nationale qui dit c'est lui c'est elle
etc ce qui est sûr c'est que j'ai lu un
article excellent de Public Sénat
d'ailleurs qui interrogé les
parlementaires écologistes sur ce qu'ils
en pensaient et on voit que les sénateur
et les sénatrices du groupe écolo en
grande majorité disent bah ce serait
intéressant parce qu'on dit parfois que
le Sénat c'est pas là où se passe les
choses que c'est un peu trop loin etc
bah au moins enfin je vais vous dire que
qu'une personnalité politique de
l'ampleur de Yannick Jadot dise moi
c'est le Sénat qui m'intéresse je pense
que ça fait plaisir aussi à beaucoup de
personnes qui aiment le Sénat et je
voilà évidemment que dans notre
mouvement il y a beaucoup de gens qui
trouvent ça intéressant mais la question
c'est parce que ce que moi j'en pense et
ce qu'il peut apporter au Sénat ce qu'il
peut apporter à l'écologie et je pense
évidemment il peut apporter beaucoup de
choses à ces deux institutions mais du
coup qui sera peut-être de liste
européenne ah bah ça vous allez très
vite en besogne on est en train de se
refonder on se donne 50 150 jours pour
faire ça évidemment qu'on est en train
de travailler en temps masqué sur les
européennes mais franchement c'est pas
le moment non plus de répondre à cette
question parce que je peux vous dire
c'est que c'est une élection qui nous
tient à cœur qu'on y réfléchit depuis
longtemps et que ce sera
la liste ah non absolument pas parce que
on est pour le nom cumul chez nous donc
moi je suis secrétaire national je
prendrai toute ma part évidemment dans
cette campagne j'adore les campagnes je
serai en soutien la tête de liste mais
ce ne sera pas moi juste les avions
bah c'est au moins c'est une info sur
sénatorial est-ce que vous souhaitez que
ce soit des listes d'union ou des listes
écologistes ou des listes nupug-unions
de la gauche évidemment que dans plein
de territoire on va discuter après il
est sénatoriales c'est l'élection qui
est vraiment spécifique où ça se joue
parfois à quelques quelques voix de
grands électeurs on discute d'ores et
déjà avec le Parti communiste avec le
Parti socialiste dans un certain nombre
de territoires et au niveau national
comme on l'a toujours fait pour ces
élections mais les décisions seront
prises sur les territoires aux plus
justes et en concertation avec les
adhérents et avec ses partenaires et une
dernière question sur le nucléaire oui
avec le gouvernement bien qui pourrait
mobiliser l'épargne du livret A il a
annoncé pour financer le nucléaire
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez tout ça
j'ai un livret A je ne veux pas qu'ils
serve à financer le nucléaire aidez-moi
madame Tondelier parlez-en la télé donc
merci de me poser cette question mais
vraiment le nucléaire c'est un fiasco il
faut le dire le père de Flamanville qui
devait coûter 3 milliards et ouvrir en
2012 on est déjà à plus de 20 milliards
et toujours pas ouvert on sait pas quand
il ouvrira si n'importe quel filière en
France avait connu en tel on arrêterait
le fiasco là on dit bah non on va en
faire 6 EPR on sait pas en faire un on
va en faire 6 et vraiment ça a trop
coûté parce que la fin c'est les
contribuables qu'il aille ça
aujourd'hui
EDF et en difficulté mais bon l'état
vient à rescousse c'est-à-dire le
contribuable français donc franchement
moi je préfère que mon Livret A finance
des éoliennes des énergies renouvelables
qui sont renouvelables qui sont
complètement des carbonées qui ne font
pas vivre
l'économie de Poutine avec ses sociétés
qui à la fois nous fournissent l'uranium
elle elle fait transiter ou traite nos
déchets nucléaires qui ne produisent pas
des déchets que nos enfants
petits-enfants arrière petits-enfants
sur des milliers de générations auront à
subir qui sont dangereux
climatique
ce ne soit pas là que l'argent soit pris
sur nucléaire merci beaucoup marine
Tondelier d'avoir été avec nous la Une
de La Nouvelle République manifestation
la rue dans les bars vers les bars merci
beaucoup
Eric berger merci marine tondeuse